the history of ever
bill so-called micro foundation
people call I mean it's amazing how
here's a here's a no one ever learns
theorem right over and over again
enthusiasm will break out in economics
for building Microsystems we put it
building micro foundations of macro
models well we should learn and stop
right because every one of them crashes
into this problem fairly quickly make
that you wind up with with more than one
way right of reconstructing your macro
at compute you've got a bunch of data
you build them out you test the
macroeconomic model you test to test the
kind of everything fitting very very
nicely and then it turns out there's
more than one micro economic story that
you can tell about it right and and
therefore will generate the macro model
but could regenerate predictions not
just about macro states but typically
you're trying to generate predictions
about micro state and you'll discover
the to the to generate different
predictions depending upon which of
several micro economic stories is taken
to be the foundations of the macro story
does that mean that when this happens
you have a macro model which is adequate
for the data you've seen yeah and so
what you'd like to be able to do is say
see now I'm on the right track I have
this macro model which which covers the
data quite handily here's the micro meat
model to drive fun but the trouble isn't
there's another micro model which using
the same rigorous derivation see gives
use the same macro model and those two
micro theories disagree at some point I
don't you well it's important the future
then they must disagree with evidence in
the world right you're calling on as you
gather more evidence one model will be
falsified one micro model
falsified and the other one well that's
right but I thought Simon your point was
more about two macro models from the
same micro not two micro models giving
the same back yes so this is coarse
grains of the same underlying so let me
give you I can give you my favorite
example but a medical model is of coarse
graining of macro models of coarse
graining of a micro models sure but but
there might be more than one so just
just like for the macro model there
might be more than one substrate if we
know the micro model we know it's at us
in the room bumping into each other and
we've said several times you derived
fluid mechanics or thermodynamics from
that right well but that's not an
innocent statement you know there's a
there's a specific process that we go
through you smooth over regions of space
and then we sort of have average
quantities and we can we find
miraculously versus my miraculously that
we can have a theory that is sort of
good in its own right and is much much
simpler and therefore we've learned
something powerful about the world we
might have chosen because the initial
Theory depended on positions and
velocities of the atoms we might have
chosen to smooth over regions of
velocity space instead of regions of
space no one can stop you from doing
that but when you get see what you get
is a different coarse graining of the
atomic theory in the room and it would
be an utter mess it would be like it
this huge ten to the twenty three
equations governing all these unknowns
with non-local weird it could be
completely useless because there is no
regularity there to be found by
averaging and in momentum space rather
than native position space but what and
then your your your logical point is
that I would never be able to know
whether or not those two theories
conventional fluid dynamics and weird
momentum theory where were the same
underlying exactly when there is in
general no principle and I'm standing as
I'm going to
but this is these are the kinds of
points that you get into it's not so
absolutely you wouldn't know these to
work could actually be derived you
couldn't tell if they were in general as
noble to tell these are actually the
same that they agree right and sorry I
sort of I guess it's a maybe a
cautionary note that even the synchronic
immersion stuff is hard physical
theories fix all the physical facts that
is it seems obvious and it seem like
it's got to be true but it's no more
true than mathematical statistics on the
mathematical facts so they ask a quick
question just to cut beyond this um this
there's sort of two classic ways of
people have divided emergence theories
one is epistemological and one is
ontological we've been arguing over the
ontological side of things you've told
me about model theory that says there's
an epistemological problem here how does
it address the ontological question or
does it
you